ابقى في اوكرانيا ولكن بالعوده الى الهجوم
الصاروخيه الاوكراني الذي استهدف مبنى يضم
قوات روسيه في منطقه مكيفكا بمقاطعات
دونيس وذلك ليله راس السنه
مكالمات باستخدام الهواتف المحموله مكنا
جيش الاوكراني من استخدام البيانات التي
تضمنتها الهواتف لتحديد مواقع القوات
الروسيه وشن الهجوم الصاروخي عليها
كيف يمكن لجهاز هاتف محمول صغير ان يصبح
احد اسلحه الحرب الفتاكه هذا ما حدث ليله
راس السنه الجديده في منطقه ماكيه بمقاطعه
حيث تم استهداف مبنا يضم قوات روسيه
بحسب نتائج تحقيق خلصت اليها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اجرى جنود من روس مكالمات
باستخدام الهواتف المحموله
فمكنت البيانات التي تضمنتها هذه الهواتف
الجيش الاوكراني من حساب الاحداثيات
لتحديد مواقع القوات الروسيه وجنه هجوم
صاروخي ادى الى مقتل عشرات الجنود الروس
في واحده من اكثر الضربات الدمويه منذ بدء
الحرب خلال الحرب ثقلت كل من اوكرانيا
وروسيا مهاراتهم في استخدام اشارات
الهواتف المحموله والراديو اداه استهداف
فعاله ورغم ان بعض احداث الروسيه
والاوكرانيه تتبع قواعد صارمه تضمن عدم
وجود الهواتف المحموله بالقرب من الخطوط
الاماميه تظهر منشورات وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي من ساحه المعركه ان الهواتف
المحموله شائعه بين الجنود على كلا
الجانبين بل ان بعض الجنرالات الروس
انفسهم اجر مكالمات عبر الهواتف واجهزه
الراديو غير الامنه في وقت مبكر من الحرب
مما مكن الاوكرانيين من تحديد اماكنهم
وقتل جنرال واحد على الاقل بسبب مكالمه تم
اعتراضها وفقا لما نقلته صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز عن مسؤولين عسكريين امريكيين حاليا
وسابقين يقول المسؤولون الاوكرانيون ان
القوات المدعومه من روسيا استخدمت بيانات
الهواتف المحموله لاستهداف الجنود
الاوكرانيين منذ عام واربعه عشر عندما بدا
الانفصاليون الموالون للكرملين في قتال
القوات الاوكرانيه في شرق اوكرانيا ويبدو
ان استخدام الهواتف المحموله الشخصيه امر
ابتليت به كل من اوكرانيا وروسيا مما جعل
القوه عرضه لخطر قطعه التكنولوجيا هذه
التي مهما كانت عاديه ومنتشره في كل مكان
من الحياه اليوميه فانها يمكن ان تشكل
تهديدا وجوديا في الحرب
للحديث عن الهاتف الجوال كسلاح رقمي في
هذه الحرب يعود معنا من بيروت العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه عميد الياس حنا ان صحت
الروايه الروسيه التي تقول ان ما حدث في
مكيفك واستهداف هذا العدد الكبير من
الجنود الروس ليله راس السنه تم بسبب
استخدام الجنود للهاتف الجوال ماذا يعني
اساسا ان يلجا الجنود لاستخدام هواتفهم
الجوال الشخصيه في المعارك هل هذا همم
يعني متعرف عليها هل هذا مقبول
ال سي الامر ليس مقبولا لانه هناك ما يسمى
بالامن العملاني للوحدات المقاتله يعني
عندما تقاتل الوحدات يجب ان يكون هناك امن
يحمل يحمي امنها كيف تستطيع القتال اليوم
نتحدث هذه حجه بسيطه وهي جزء من عده اسباب
لهذه الكارثه التي حصلت على الجيش الروسي
يعني عندما تحملين همم خلوي انما تستعملين
همم ابراج اتصالات هذه الابراج يكفي ان
يكون هذا الخلوي متصل بثلاثه ابراج كي
يحدث ما يسمى بالترينجوليشن او عمليه
التسليس تقاطع ثلاثه خطوط فتعطي ما يسمى
بالاحداثيات ولكن هذا الامر بسيط جدا
السينتحدث عن همم مركز فيه اكثر من 400
شخص من الجنود الجدد مخازن ذخيره بعيد عن
الجبهه 13 كلم والكثير منهم يستعمل همم اا
الجوال لماذا لا نتحدث عن ما يسمى بالنت
وركينج لدى الجيش الاوكراني الذي ابتكر
طريقه مهمه تربط الجندي بالسلاح بالمسيره
ريل تايم بنفس الوقت وبالتالي هناك صور
جويه يمكن التعرف عليها يعني هذا المركز
ممكن قصفه بالعمر وحتى ممكن قصفه بذخيره
ال 155 الذكيه الاكس كلبر التي لا تخطئ
مطلقا ابدا هذه المشكله الاساسيه الخلل
بالعملان وهذا امر لم يحدث لاول مره على
صعيد الجيش الروسي في استعمال الشبكه
الاوكرانيه ال سي هي المهم الشبكه
الاوكرانيه وليست الشبكه الروسيه وليس
لجونس بل جي بي اس
في هذه الحلقه عبد الياس نتكلم عن فشل
استخباراتي فشر فشل
عملياتي من قبل الجيش الروسي
هو فشل عبد القادر هو فشل عمليتي
فشل في القياده والسيطره ان تضع 400 جندي
من الجدد ليس لديه الخبره العمليه على على
الجبهه تقريبا يعني هم جنوب سباته
وكريمينا وهم شمال اا مخموط وهذه منطقه
مشتعله جدا جدا جدا تصل لها كل انواع
القذائف والمدفعيه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
ضمنا الهايمرز هذه في مفهوم القياده في
مفهوم الانتباه وهذا الامر يتحدث عنه
الروس بحد ذاته من انتقدوا هذه العمليه
يعني هذا فشل استخباراته فشل في حمايه
الامن العاملاني للقوه العسكريه لن نتحدث
عن شخص يعني هذا الامر يكفي ان يكون هناك
20 او 30 شخصا لديهم ما يسمى الجوال اللي
يكون ما يسمى بشاتنج يعني المراقبه التنصل
تعرف ان الهدف ذات معنى استراتيجي مهم جدا
السؤال هو لماذا هؤلاء الجنود الجدد كما
ذكرت الى استخدام هذه الهواتف الشخصيه همم
ما دلالات ذلك خصوصا وان القوى الغربيه
الداعمه لاوكرانيا تشير الى ان هذا بسبب
نقص المعددات لدى الجيش الروسي هل هذا
صحيح
بالطبع عرسي هناك نقص في المعدات هناك نقص
في همم التسليح هناك نقص في التدريب يعني
هذا الذي استدعي منذ شهر او شهرين همم درب
لفتره شهر ووضع على الجبهه وهذا امر خطير
جدا لماذا لانه حجم العمليات واهميتها همم
تتطلب خبرات كبيره من العسكر ذات خبره
عاليه وهذا الامر لا يحصل حاليا لماذا
لانه في المرحله الاولى والمرحله الثانيه
تم استهلاك واستنزاف النخبه العسكريه من
قوات الجيش الروسي من هنا هذا الامر نتحدث
عن السلاح نتحدث عن اللوجستيه لاتحدث عن
اللباس التجيد والذخيره ونوعيه القياده
والسيطره لانه ان يقتل اكثر من جنرال بسبب
استعمال لخط مفتوح كما يقول نطق كلير كما
يقال او كلير هذا امر صعب جدا على مستوى
دوله عظمى او دوله كبرى شكرا جزيلا لك على
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العميد الياس
ح نا ضيفنا من بيروت